reducing co2 emissions from new light
commercial vehicles sold in the eu by
2020 saw meps approve a limit of 147
grams per kilometer down from 203 grams
per kilometer on tuesday this is a
long-term average target for
manufacturers across their entire fleet
any highly pleating vehicle must be
balanced off by greener models or the
manufacturer faces a penalty some meps
claim that the approved tax does not go
far enough and will come as a welcome
relief to the automotive industry
and
mep sent out clear message to member
states and the commission do not use a
crisis as an excuse for demolishing
social security vulnerable groups should
have access to social protection
self-employed workers should also be
guaranteed access to social protection
irrespective of their status
in 2012 32.8 million europeans were
self-employed
um
every year european citizens use on
average 466 plastic bags
most end up as litter and impact our
ecosystem in a resolution parliament has
urged for a reduction of plastic waste
setting targets for the sorting
collection and recycling processes just
25 of plastic waste is currently
recyclable
parliament is now waiting for the
recommendations of the european
executive before advancing on the issue
in 2014